je suis à marseille pour rencontrer et
dc policiers et membres du syndicat fo
unité police
bonjour et dc merci de répondre à nos
questions à marseille voilà on se trouve
devant un commissariat le commissariat
du 12ème arrondissement vous avez
travaillé durant plusieurs années à
paris et quelles sont les différences
notables entre la police marseillaise et
la police parisienne à l'audience et le
nombre de moyens mais effectivement
c'est le manque de moyens parce que par
la seule bonne raison qu'on a beaucoup
moins de fonctionnaires à disposition la
banlieue proche a beaucoup plus de
moyens humains donc ici on en est
vraiment cruellement d'effectifs de
police première chose et secundo c'est
le souk al ibrahim la vidéoprotection de
la vidéo-verbalisation dire que c'est on
a très peu de caméras aujourd'hui qui
nous permet de pouvoir lutter
efficacement contre la délinquance de
voie publique et ça c'est vrai que c'est
un manque de moyens criant donc humain
est aussi effectivement technologique
aujourd'hui quels sont les besoins
essentiels de la police française c'est
vraiment et je le répète c'est
malheureusement mais c'est une vérité
c'est vraiment les effectifs ont là un
tiers du déficit foncier promis on
entend encore les deux tiers on espère
qu'ils arriveront courant 2022 c'est la
promesse qui n'a été faite par nos
dirigeants on verra si elles sont
respectées le fait que là-bas qu'ils
étaient pris pour cible la banque
marseillaise est ce qu est ce qu on a
franchi un cap dans la cité phocéenne
alors il est indéniable qu'il ya qui me
quinzaine de jours le sable ou les
collègues effectivement de la bac la bac
nord en l'occurrence ont été pris à
partie ont été mises en joue d'abord
effectivement dans un premier temps par
les individus qui ont été appréhendés
pris à partie ils n'ont eu effectivement
la vie sauve que grâce à la présence des
murs et d'alleyras lequel ils se sont
cachés donc oui oui effectivement on a
franchi un cap pourquoi parce que nous
gênons les trafiquants et la stratégie
du harcèlement de fait c'est le but
harcèle et les gènes les délais risquent
super chiant qui sont je le rappelle
aujourd'hui une manne financière
dantesque on parle de 30 à 90 milles
euros par jour de chiffre d'affaires par
points de deal à marseille alors il
décide je propose que vous nous emmenez
un peu dans ce quartier dit sensible ces
zones on appelle de non droit en tout
cas c'est comme ça qu'on les appelle
dans la cité phocéenne oui avec plaisir
effectivement nous allons ne citons pas
y aller effectivement il ya beaucoup à
voir et à découvrir la partie
[Musique]
alors on est d'accord que le trafic de
drogue ça va être très haut pour la cité
phocéenne mais est ce qu'une fois que
vous arrêtez ces trafiquants qui est
quand même de multiples interpellations
les sanctions à son assez lourde sur le
plan judiciaire l avarie la
problématique c'est les places
disponibles en prison ou les mesures
alternatives d'éloignement des jeunes
mineurs effectivement trempant dans
trafic de stupéfiants pour leur éviter
de devenir des narcotrafiquants mais là
on fait pas ça à
la jeunesse et rassurez vous les de
l'actualité bah ouais voilà
ils ont vérifié qu'il n'était pas la
police a bola
certains élus ou une idée c est de
légaliser le cannabis pour que les
forces de l'ordre se concentre sur les
plus gros trafiquants ce que c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise idée selon pr
nettement
d'avoir un discours aussi angélique est
aussi simple sur un sujet aussi complexe
qu'elle est ravie de super chiant c'est
vraiment être sur l'appel hors-sol
penser que les individus vent gentiment
se mettre à ouvrir des coffee shops a
essayé à payer des charges donc valurent
ça fou ou payer la tva alors que l'on
est en face d'un individu
qui n'hésitent pas à exécuter
sommairement leurs concurrents une fois
que ces deux individus ont été exécutés
qu'ils en mettent si je puis dire des
balles dans la tête pour éviter que leur
mère les amasser une dernière fois voilà
les amis du coup l'on a en face de nous
ce qui fait aujourd'hui la rareté
l'importance d'aider la qualité si je
puis dire des narcos d'aider des
stupéfiants et des produits stupéfiants
c'est ce qu'on appelle tôt thc c'est à
dire en l'occurrence le taux de ce qui
permet de planer pour vulgariser un peu
la chose et en général il est entre 5 et
30 % approche puisque 30% aujourd'hui
c'est quand même un signe important ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon
narcotrafiquants la frappe donc si
l'état demain été amené ce que je
n'espère jamais voir le jour à légaliser
comme dans d'autres pays si un tel cas
ils vont tout de suite influer sur le
taux therach'i le problème du tout est à
chier c'est qu'en fait très simplement
oui très simplement le tout est haché
effectivement et on va le faire
descendre à 5 ou 10% et donc les
narcotrafiquants se mettront à vendre ce
qu'on appelle de la frappe donc des
produits avec un th est beaucoup plus
important qu'ils soient demandées par
les clients solution ce n'est à aucun
moment probablement une solution
quelques avec les puissent être
effectivement
ou alors ici on est dans une des cités
chaudes il ya des zones un peu de
non-droit aussi également comment ça se
passe le quotidien pour les riverains
ici et dans cette cité alors aujourd'hui
on une cité des quartiers nord et un
règlement de compte cet été un double
homicide effectivement à la kalachnikov
sur deuxième division qui en a laissé
peu ou pas de répit ils ont été abattus
à bout portant est achevée effectivement
un temps ensoleillé agonisant donc c'est
une cité effectivement ou des compliqué
de vivre surtout pour les habitants on
est dans un secteur dit populaire où
malheureusement le trafic de stupéfiants
un fait vivre toute une pente pépin de
l'économie et de la population
maintenant aujourd'hui les dommages sont
vraiment pour les habitants serait
effectivement le cas échéant de balle
perdue ou au malheureusement de dommage
collatéral possible et probable lorsque
les habitants de la cité passe au moment
des faits en l'occurrence des règlements
de compte la préfète des bouches du
rhône cette semaine a déclaré que les
zones de non-droit n'existait presque
c'est votre avis également alors à mes
yeux les ombres n'existe pas marché car
les forces de l'ordre dans tous les
quartiers de marseille et ça je pèse mes
mots dans tous les quartiers l'écart
sionards commun carsud maintenant oui
effectivement il ya des endroits où nous
rentrons un seul véhicule il ya des
endroits où nous devons entrer à
plusieurs véhicules pour pouvoir
sécuriser les nous mêmes nos véhicules
travailler en sécurité pour nous et pour
les habitants aux alentours se demande
affaire emmanuelle m'apprend ça serait
quoi aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
effectivement la demande que nous
faisons c'est que les efforts qui ont
été promis aujourd'hui soit accentuée et
soient concrétisées nous avons bon
espoir seul cas mais n'hésiteront pas
effectivement la dénoncer si ce n'est
pas le cas